Anybody here happened to be from Korea?
Hey,
born there.
Even from soul.
Yeah.
Ah,
you may know about this.
Okay.
So there's a,
there's a,
do you know about the oldest tree in soul?
Hello?
So this is the oldest tree in soul.
It's a Ginkgo tree,
uh,
and it's supposed to be 840 years old.
That's a really old tree.
And it's venerated by the residents.
It's kind of a,
uh,
a holy sacred tree.
And they bring fruit.
They bring other offerings once a year and pray among other things for their
safety.
But it's real advantage is that it helps pregnant women to have a boy child.
And so this is a very important transit we'll do.
Do you know about this tree?
Yes.
Okay.
Gingko is one of the few kinds of trees that has male and female sex.
Most trees are hermaphrodite have both male and female sex.
Anyway,
it turns out they ran into a problem with this tree because two apartment
buildings were interfering with the tree's roots as,
as the cheese spread its roots.
So what happens to the district government spend four point $3 million to take
down the apartment buildings.
So it just shows to show you the importance and the,
uh,
political acceptability,
the cultural acceptability of son preference.
It's a very,
very big factor in the world.
The sex ratio is a very important biological factor.
If we have time at the end,
I'll,
I'll tell you a good bit about it,
but just to show you that it's very well controlled.
A biologically,
this is one of several theories about how the sex ratio in humans gets to be
what it is that sperms are 50,
50,
because there's a hundred male sperms to a hundred,
a female sperms.
And that's because,
uh,
the sex is determined by the father and the father has one x and one y.
And when they split to go into separate sperms,
one gets an x one gets why that's even,
but by the second month of gestation,
so this is still in the mother's room,
apparently a huge fraction of about one third of the male fetuses are have died
leaving
uh,
um,
I'm sorry,
of the female fetuses have died cause now it's,
it's a high male ratio.
Then as time goes on,
the female fetuses start to die.
And when you end up,
you get 106 at birth all over the world unless people are messing with it.
There's about 106 male burst.
Every hundred female births.
This is a very,
a very fixed number.
So for instance,
the United States in 1969 there were 105.3 males born per hundred females.
Uh,
1995,
30 something years later,
104.9.
So difference of 0.4,
that number really does not very,
except basically between 105 and 106.
It's a very,
very stable number.
Okay.
So,
given that you can look at some parts of the world and see something like this,
this is again,
the sex ratio and you can look over time,
1972 to 1992 a 20 years span.
And here's Japan where they started a little bit of x.
Here's,
here's the numbers you should expect.
Somewhere in this range they have somewhat of an excess of boy,
but very minor.
And then during this period of time,
Japan came down to almost exactly that one or six number would look at what's
going on in China
up to 113 or so,
which means basically seven out of every hundred girls who are being done away
with 7%,
no sure.
That's not anywhere near the,
the worst case.
So what do you think is,
is,
uh,
the cause of this
unreal
mitochondrial DNA?
Yup.
So you think it's a very longterm evolutionary,
what she's saying is she thinks there's,
there's stuff that,
uh,
the,
the why the sperm,
the y,
the y chromosome has very few genes.
The x chromosome has many genes there.
Looks like there's a long evolutionary process,
uh,
by which genes are getting eliminated on the why and the venture,
the y we'll then have nothing on it and disappear.
But this is much too short a time.
We're talking 10 years.
Evolution just doesn't happen in 10 years,
but it's a good,
good thought.
Okay,
sure.
Whining,
very good.
This is this,
this is the most usual answer is the one child policy in China.
This is China,
remember?
And the one child policy.
So people have heard of the one child policy and we're going to give lectures
on,
does that sound like a good hypothesis for you?
Yeah,
but just saying it doesn't make it true.
So what else is that?
This is at birth.
You image you wanted son.
I presume that the greatest way to manage that would be through fantasize.
Very good.
Uh,
idea.
What she says is,
look,
this is at birth and then,
okay,
you're getting ahead.
We'll,
we'll good.
I'm glad all this,
this discussion.
Let's notice one other thing.
One child policy.
When does the one child policy start?
We'll come back to these.
These explanations.
They're all good.
Anybody know?
Okay.
Guess right about 1979,
1980,
when does this take off?
Right?
So that looks like now we've got at least a second piece of evidence that it's,
the time sequence fits very nicely with,
uh,
the one child policy.
So how can we check that we're still,
you know,
we have to be very skeptic about everything that anyone tells you that that's
the scientific attitude.
Anything anybody tells you.
Politics,
science,
religion,
economics.
Try to say something.
Immediate gut responses.
That's nonsense.
Prove it to me.
So I'm not convinced yet.
So what else might you do?
You did fine.
You could find data on abortions.
Good.
We'll,
we'll look at that room.
We talk about China,
but we might look at other countries that don't have the one child policy,
right?
So here's another country.
This is India.
And you have,
remember the,
the Chinese,
uh,
and,
and this is a somewhat different,
it's a dead,
is that this is not,
not at birth,
but the total population,
which is less extreme,
but a comparable number for China would be here.
So India is more extreme than China.
It is a bad example because before I prices are so high.
There are reasons.
Other reasons in India there's clearly reasons all around and there may be
different in different places,
but the,
but the main hypothesis that we are working on it and come back to that,
it's very important.
The main I positive that we're working on is that it's one child policy in
China,
but now we see that China is not particularly extreme take compared to India.
It depends on what year you look and exactly what statistic you look.
It's really in the same ballpark with India.
So now we have to say that,
well it's probably not one child policy.
So what's our next hypothesis?
We've heard,
we've heard a different one for China.
India has bride price,
but then if you start with Indian,
say that China doesn't have bride price,
they have dowery may have in fact the opposite.
So what about
excellent.
That's something but,
but why are the one doing poverty?
That's the usual thing.
When you speak of India and China in these years,
they were still very,
I mean they're,
they're still quite poor,
but it was poverty.
So how does that strike you as a,
as a hypothesis for this?
We're part of it.
I mean there's,
these things are multi causal.
China's economy has been taking off,
but it's,
the ratios are still going up.
Well he only shot,
I'm going to show you that data,
but I only showed you the data up to 1990 a 92.
Uh,
so I haven't,
I'm going to show you that.
Uh,
okay.
So again,
we can go to an international comparison if we want to see if poverty is at the
root of this and what are we looking at here?
Korea,
South Korea.
Korea is not a poor country,
right?
And yet they are just as bad,
in fact,
a little bit more extreme than China at this time.
So,
uh,
we really have,
quite a conundrum that we can give particular exercises for each place,
but they're going to maybe going to be different
population growth.
It could be population growth in general.
That's certainly true of all of the three countries,
that there's something about the density of population,
hard to prove since India and China is very crowded for a very long time.
And Korea is also crowded but not as extremely as,
as,
as China and India.
Okay.
So not the greatest sex ratio is in South Korea,
which is you heard is not poor.
And by 2010,
there will be a 20% deficit in the marriage age.
There'll be a 20% deficit of,
of females in Korea,
which is quite a,
quite high.
And that's a way with,
so the,
the,
uh,
the poverty thing,
the economic thing does not work between countries.
And even if you look,
I'll show you a little bit later this big regional variations within each,
each country.
Uh,
but it doesn't go with economics at all.
So in China,
uh,
in Guangdong,
Guangdong,
which can't on which everything,
everything you're wearing and everything he played with,
including probably this is maiden,
somewhere in Guangdong province,
uh,
probably.
And so it's one of the richer places in China.
And the sex ratio,
there is 130 to 100 something.
I showed you 12 to 14.
In that province,
it goes up to 130 and parts of that province.
So of course,
even within a province,
there's,
there's different places they can go up to 144 to 100.
So something like a third of the girls are done away with.
Yeah.
No,
Brian Bride price doesn't happen in either China or India.
Bride price,
you remember is when the man's family gives something to the girl or the girl's
family.
Dowery is the opposite.
And dowery is,
is common in India.
And really it was really communist got rid of it.
Any,
any vestige of that in,
in China.
So that,
that's not the case.
So in India,
the same thing,
uh,
the states,
in New Delhi and Hariana,
which are the richer places there,
uh,
have more extreme sex ratios than poor places.
And,
uh,
is in,
in Delhi,
that's 861 females per thousand,
uh,
males,
at birth.
And
so as time goes on,
as you see,
the sex ratios are getting worse and the,
the answer to our problem of what his car is causing,
what caused things to change at this point in time is what someone here said.
What,
what did someone say?
Something that would,
it wasn't the one she is the one child policy happened at this time,
but something else happened in both India and China and Korea.
Okay.
It has to do with technology.
Perfect
for knowing the sex,
uh,
before birth and what,
what is the technology that's commonly used ultrasound that at that time
ultrasound came in and became a rather inexpensive and available.
The two ways of doing it or amniocentesis,
which is somewhat difficult medically and quite expensive,
but ultrasound,
you don't need an awful lot of training.
The equipment is not terribly expensive.
It costs I think about $14 in,
in India in this period of time to get an ultrasound test of what your,
uh,
your,
your fetus was.
So,
uh,
in one of the counties in,
in China for instance,
that they started doing ultrasound.
And what happened was the first child,
and I'll show you some data that was okay if it was a girl,
but if the second,
if they had a first girl and the second child was also a girl,
then 92% of the time,
uh,
the girls would be boarded.
And I think in your reading it talks about an India in 8,000.
They,
they looked at 8,000 serial abortions in a particular hospital and 7,999 were
females,
one was a male and that that was probably a mistake.
They just read.
I didn't read the ultrasound.
Right.
And it's not always easy to do it.
So what's happening is that in India and in China,
it's illegal in both places,
but the have even sidewalk clinics that you can just go and,
and,
and get a little ultrasound.
Does.
How many of you have had some sort of ultrasound?
Yeah.
Yeah,
it's very,
they take a little probe about that long and this and just run her over you.
And a picture on a TV screen and,
and,
and you know,
whatever your heart or your lungs or your baby,
whatever's going on.
So,
uh,
that's,
that's what's going on.
It's the cheap,
I'll ultrasound a doctors in a lot of places,
doctors,
it's so fast to do this.
It's so cheap,
doesn't take much skill that in a lot of plays doctors that he's giving up all
the rest of their practice and just doing ultrasound.
It's,
it's,
it's sort of like liposuction here or something.
It's,
it's uh,
easy and,
uh,
easy and cheap and they make a lot of women a lot of money with this.
So the head of the Women's Association in India says,
no one wants girls.
If the test says a girl than the pregnant woman will have an abortion.
Uh,
and so someone else also mentioned this,
I think that the final sex ratio,
uh,
not at birth as,
as we said,
what their hand is.
One of you picked out the fact that this is at birth means it's not an
infanticide issue.
This is something doing before birth.
The only thing you can do before birth is sex selective abortion.
So it's clearly the mechanism of this and the timing is clearly the introduction
of ultrasound put the total sex ratio of the country hasn't changed all that
much.
Then in China we have pretty good data and traditionally wherever one has data,
there has been a,
uh,
a dearth of about 10 to 25% of girls from,
they have data back to the 17 hundreds.
That's,
that's pretty decent.
But back then it was infanticide.
So what you're really seeing is a change of method that the society is going
from an infanticide control of the sex ratio to an ultrasound and,
uh,
and sex selective abortion,
control of the sex ratio.
So the,
apparently the desire and the,
and the cultural desire for,
for males hasn't changed all that much,
but technology has,
has changed what they do.
And to most people's mind,
uh,
it's,
an abortion is,
is a,
is a better thing than that,
an infanticide.
But,
uh,
you can make up your own mind about that.
So let me give you some more data that of the various questions that you've all
asked.
Um,
one is an update in time.
So that particular slide,
uh,
stopped in,
in that figure.
The dataset stopped in 1992 in this picks up a little bit later.
And here is again,
India,
five states there and in the most extreme states,
which again are the richest,
not the poorest of poor.
Uh,
this is a poor state.
These are rich states.
This is southern states there.
Oh,
there's different reasons.
We'll come to that in a moment.
But here we saw ratios of,
of one,
uh,
one 14 or so,
and now they've gone up to one 29 and slowly getting better,
a little bit better with time out to the last census in 2000,
uh,
six,
data.
And these are two,
uh,
well off,
provinces and they're extreme.
Southern India is,
uh,
the,
the in the north India,
they speak Hindi,
mostly Hindi related languages in the South Dravidian lady related languages.
Uh,
the Muslim invasions didn't quite reach the south of India.
A lot of differences between north and south India.
In terms of demography or culture,
almost anything.
It's,
it's crazy to talk about India.
You cannot talk about India.
It's so diverse.
China,
they've convinced the people that their one culture.
But in India that's not the case.
So you really have to compare this as one kind of these two states as one kind
of country.
And this is very close to the,
to the one o six level.
So this is,
and also just weirdly in,
in uh,
in most places it's the number of boys to girls.
But in India,
the way they define sex ratios,
the opposite.
So I've translated into these,
these,
the numbers that are comparable to what,
what you've been been hearing.
Okay.
That's India.
Here is China.
Again,
it has gone more extreme.
So we stopped here about 1992 and the one 12 range.
And uh,
this is at birth age zero.
So we're looking at this line that start that's here and that has now gone up to
one 18,
one 19.
The sex ratio at birth.
And then as the child grows older,
as,
as the set of children that you're counting grows older,
the sex ratio gets more and more skewed as time goes on.
And we look at that in a little bit.
Uh,
it is,
uh,
very diverse.
I mentioned this very,
very diverse by province.
Here again is India.
So Carola,
uh,
as I mentioned to it,
they're very poor.
Carol is a very poor state in India,
one of the poorest,
but they had a communist government for long time and very that a,
a matriarchal,
their traditional system was matrix,
not matriarchal,
matrilineal.
So women have more power for a lot of reasons.
Uh,
Carola has been doing very good on social indicators of social progress and look
at it.
This is child mortality from zero to five through the first five years here and
males six,
uh,
six per thousand,
Maldef,
4.5 females,
very low desk.
Compare that to Bihar.
A very poor state where 50 or 60 up to 70,
almost deaths.
It's a factor of,
of of 10 or 15 for females.
The difference between our different states in India and the same thing,
uh,
in China.
Here is,
uh,
sorry,
why did I ah,
what I want,
what I wanted to show you about that slide was,
well forget it for a moment.
This is China and you have again,
very different.
This is sex ratio at birth,
SRB,
sex ratio at birth and over different periods of time,
1980 to 90 and so forth.
Those are between the green,
which is a normal ratio,
even bias toward females.
This is almost within the normal range.
This would be biased toward females and uh,
Tibet,
the far western provinces,
uh,
are,
are either normal or even bias toward females.
And that is a cultural difference because you have,
these are Muslim provinces in the Qur'an forbids the killing of daughters.
So Muslim countries in general do not have this,
these very skewed sex ratios to bed of course is Buddhist.
And they also don't do this.
But in the hon regions,
the heartland of China,
especially around 2000 2005,
you know,
very high ratio,
120 to 138 and change,
it's changing a little bit slowly.
So as time goes on,
we see they go from uh,
the 112 that we talked about,
the blue regions,
they are being disappearing and you're getting more extreme situation here in
China.
So again,
you can pick out,
depending on if,
if,
if you look at [inaudible] more culturally homogeneous regions,
you get either very low numbers,
are very high numbers.
Uh,
now here's another thing which I mentioned.
It depends terribly much on parody how many children they already have.
So for a first birth,
uh,
this is as China and the going out to the year 2000.
And this is the deal.
This is a parody here.
And this is,
uh,
the different censuses.
So the latest census,
2005,
I think is this census here.
And for first birth it's,
it's one oh seven.
It's pretty normal,
little bit elevated,
but by second birth it goes in enormously up.
And you're into like one 40 or a prior census,
one 50.
So a 50% difference in boys and girls.
And that it's extreme.
There is the one child policy is,
is pushing that because they're only allowed,
we'll talk a lot about that.
And this is not really true anymore,
but in principle they are allowed only one child to get these various high
ratios here.
And then by three children,
four or five children,
uh,
the,
the sex ratio is,
is,
is enormous.
And you may sort of have a little thing in your mind,
wait a minute,
one child policy and here they have one child and having to child and having
three children,
having four children,
there were five children.
You know what's going on.
And we're going to talk about that.
So here is,
and again,
you don't want to,
you don't want to nail this too hard to the one child policy,
uh,
because here is South Korea.
And uh,
again,
this is an old time,
but look what it goes up to.
The same thing.
So you look at the most recent numbers on this graph and for first birth,
it's a quite a normal ratio.
Second birth that gets bigger by third birth,
it's bigger than anything we see in China and by fourth birth it's way,
way over 237 and we saw what about one 60 or something in China would have on
the previous slide.
So again,
Korea,
no one child policy,
no government control of fertility at all.
And yet they are more extreme than China.
MMM.
At birth.
Um,
at birth,
the,
the genetic factors.
So,
uh,
boys have an x and a y chromosome and girls have two x's humans as well as every
other animal carry a lot of deleterious or even lethal mutations.
But you have them on only one chromosome.
The other chromosome will have a note in general will have a normal copy of the
gene.
And for almost every gene one normal chromosome makes enough of the proper
protein and you're live,
you're fine.
You don't even notice that you've got this deleterious mutations.
So it's only when you get a mutation from both parents that it becomes a week.
Cause the homozygous,
you're getting the Delta a bat,
a deleterious mutation of both parents,
then the person is sick that works for all the chromosomes except for the sex
chromosome.
So a female has two xs,
so this still holds for her.
She's got to be really unlucky and get bad copies from both mother and father.
But a male has one acts in the why with almost nothing on it.
So if he gets a bad ex,
he's sick.
So males are weaker.
And one of the,
the thoughts about why 106 males are born for every hundred females is that as
time goes on,
those males die during childhood because they are genetically weaker and
eventually it evens out to a hundred a hundred.
And there's good evolutionary reasons why evolution pushes a sexually
reproducing species,
a hundred males and a hundred females.
We can go into that later perhaps.
So you're seeing that this is at at birth,
right around birth,
which is still a genetic reasons and this is all of India.
You see that now the male deaths are higher than the females.
This is a sign of the genetic weakness of males,
uh,
at birth.
And when you break that down by state,
every single state,
uh,
54 to 40,
there's more male death,
71 to 68.
So what do we have?
Uh,
one of the Punjab which had high pro male ratio,
but at birth there is more male death than female.
That,
so that's,
that's a biological phenomenon that continues.
But if you look,
uh,
later to child mortality,
now we're,
we're,
we're done with the birth mortality,
we're done with sex,
selective abortion,
the sex selective abortion itself changes the sex ratio.
But then even after that,
the sex ratio keeps changing.
So here again is in the first five years after birth.
And notice again in Kerala where they don't have this sex selective,
this sex choice.
And I've showed you this,
uh,
more males than females.
That's again the normal biological issue.
But in every other state,
females are,
this is two and a half times as much.
This is four,
four times as much female mortality.
A one and a half times as much,
more than twice as much,
twice as much a half again as much.
Then in all the states of India,
with the exception of Carola,
there's an excess female mortality after birth.
That's counter biological.
And what that is is basically some infanticide,
but largely female neglect.
They get less food,
they get less good food,
they get sick,
they get taken to the doctor less often if medicines are required,
they don't get it very well.
So you see this after birth reduction in females,
uh,
also the problem just keeps,
keeps happening.
Yeah.
So this issue of the loss of females in the population is a very large
phenomenon.
Statistics.
Well,
from this data you can make fairly decent statistics for places where this is
collected.
So in India alone,
there's supposed to be something like 23 million women missing.
So add all this up new and you're 22 men in the world.
They're the,
the somewhere between an estimate and the guest mint is 100 million missing
women.
And you could say,
you know,
when you look deeper and more deeply for the rain,
we've had,
we have the sort of the proximate cause people are using,
uh,
sex,
selective abortion.
But we haven't touched much on the question of why do they want to want to do
that.
And you can just say it's traditional.
And,
and I hear a lot of discussions that say that,
and this is true.
In India's first national census,
which is 1871,
there were 98 million males,
but only 91 and a half million females already 6% of the females were missing.
Whereas in an a population which doesn't discriminate against females,
males being weaker all during the ages there get to be more and more females.
And with the older agents,
extreme excess of females.
But in India,
really in 1871,
that was quite a difference in China.
This is a Chinese book of travels from the 19th century.
And someone,
a Chinese person went to India,
went to England and observe things and came back and wrote a travel book,
uh,
for the Chinese.
And this is a quote from that England is so short if inhabitants that the
English rare rear every child that is born,
even prostitutes who bear children do not destroy them.
So that England was the dominant power of the world.
And uh,
they were,
they were invading China with the opium wars.
So of course everybody including the emperor was interested in what is England
like,
how come they're so powerful?
What's different there?
And the,
so the emperor read this and the emperor,
his response was he didn't believe that the English were so stupid.
So again,
the cultural thing that,
that,
you know,
to raise up all the children and especially the raise up all the girls is just,
uh,
not going,
in your reading packet.
It discusses a villages in India dating back to 1830 that have no girls at all.
They just do way with all the girls.
All of them are,
aren't killed.
1921,
a Somerset mom,
does that ring name and name,
ring any bells?
Uh,
uh,
he was a famous author,
wrote a lot of novels,
a lot of movies with very famous movie starts,
very popular author.
1921,
he was touring China and he came upon a little tower on a Chinese hillside with
a single small hole in the wall.
So they're walking along and there's those small tower,
a little hole in the wall and out of that whole camera,
nausea and odor.
And uh,
he asked,
he was with the Chinese guy and he asked him,
what is that?
And you know,
he thought maybe vcs dumped there something.
No,
it turns out it was a baby tower and it was just a pit dug into the ground and
surrounded with this tower and people brought excess of girls especially,
but some occasionally board and just dump them into this little boy came and
explained this to him and said that the blue boy said the four babies were
thrown in at that that morning.
This doesn't,
this particular passage and discuss the sex of the babies cause he didn't know
that there to re in there.
Uh,
and one of the quotes is the female child is regarded as a liability here in
rural areas.
Women are not even considered people.
And you'll do some reading where,
uh,
rather bias reading,
but accurate on this that,
uh,
you know,
girls often don't get names and traditionally their name,
daughter number one,
door number two,
door number three,
and all kinds of things.
So as I've mentioned,
the elimination of females is not limited to the young and a in one of your
readings or,
right.
And I guess I described it to the tribe in New Guinea where if a male died,
his widow was immediately strangled.
Do you remember that?
That changes the sex ratio?
Uh,
in India he heard about this there,
there used to be a very into this practice called Sati.
You heard a saute or sateen sometimes where the wife throws herself on the
funeral pyre of the man or in some other way does away with herself.
So this is from 1813 quite some time back.
And as a British captain named camp who's eyewitness to one of these things and
he wrote,
uh,
a description of it,
these phenomena,
a male had been sick a short time and the astrologer said that he was on the
point of death and so he was taken down to the side of the holy Ganges River to
expire.
He was immersed to his waste in the river for some time,
but he didn't die.
They brought him back to the bay,
to the Bank of the river and let him broil in.
The son didn't die.
Then they put it back in the river again.
He didn't die.
He's returned to the bank.
This kept going for 36 hours,
alternate sort of freezing and baking and finally this sick guy died.
Whether he would or would not have died anyway,
who knows the newest,
the astrologers word that he was going to die.
His wife,
he was married,
was a healthy young girl of about 16 learning.
If her husband's death,
she decided to be buried alive with his corpse to British officer.
This camp tried in vain to persuade the girl not to do it.
Then tried to persuade the mother.
Uh,
and he said that that a resolution of this type to just kill yourself was a kind
of madness.
But he had no success and he encountered not the slightest sign of either
hesitation or a great regret on either the girls part or the mother's part.
So the actual scene takes place.
The young widow accompanied by her friends proceeded to the beach where his body
lay.
He was placed in a grave about six feet deep.
The wife circled the grave seven times calling out hail God.
Hell God.
The surrounding crowd echoed her chant.
Hell God,
Heal God.
She climbed into the grave,
the captain,
this British guy moved up to within a foot of the grave to see if at the last
minute she showed any signs of reluctance,
whether her relative showed any sign of of horror.
And if you sold reluctancy might've jumped in and pulled her out.
She placed yourself in the sitting posture as her husband had been placed in
laying flat,
but a sitting posture both faced north.
So she was sitting behind his back.
She embraced the corpse with her left hand.
And reclined her head on his shoulder.
The British officers still saw no sign of regret on her part.
The other plan other hand,
she placed over her head with her four finger re erect,
which she moved in a circular direction.
The watchers then started throwing earth on them and to start burying them.
And,
and then other men as,
as the earth was put in,
they stamped on the earth to pack it down.
But she continued circling her hand until her head was completely buried.
And then she kept going for some time after that and finally stopped.
The earth was piled on and stamped down and it was two or three feet above the
heads of the in tuned.
No tear was shed by any of the relations.
Eventually the crowd dispersed and the ritual imitations and howling commenced,
but without sorrow.
So this is a long time ago and it's,
uh,
it's,
it's certainly extremely rare now if it happens at all.
There was one report of one woman in a village about 10 years ago who did it.
And you know,
this is illegal in India.
So very hard to get any decent statistics on it.
But very rarely it happens.
And this woman who killed herself on her husband Pyre was considered a paragon
of virtue and sort of like a saint because she was following the old,
uh,
religious customs and the village was very happy about it cause they got a lot
of tourists to come and revere this saint like a lady and made a lot of money
off the tourists.
But it's very rare.
Uh,
uh,
and of course this whole sex preference businesses,
not in any sense,
limited to Asia.
Hispanic women in Los Angeles were surveyed.
They want 2.8 sons on average in 0.1 gorders a factor of 28 difference that's
uh,
in Kuwait before the Gulf War.
This is the 1991 more I think.
Uh,
Barbara Walters,
who you all know did a story on,
on,
uh,
gender roles in Kuwait.
Yes.
During the Gulf War.
She was there and she noted that women customarily walk about 10 feet behind
their husbands.
And this is,
it happens in a lot of places,
in a strong sign of female deference and dependence.
The husband walks without the wife and the wife follows 10 feet behind.
You've,
you've heard of that customer.
So the war takes place.
Uh,
uh,
the,
the co the Iraqis get beat and she comes back to Kuwait,
uh,
to do another story after the war.
And she was so pleased because now the,
the,
the men walked behind the wives that the women were walking in front.
And so Barb Walthill all this is wonderful progress.
This is the American,
you know,
they're,
they're catching on over there.
And so she approached one of the woman and said,
and then the camera was rolling to catch this,
you know,
she's a TV personality.
This is marvelous.
As Barbara Walters.
Can you tell the free world just what enabled women to achieve this reversal of
roles?
And the Kuwaiti woman said land mines.
And so it wasn't a reversal at all.
Uh,
all right.
I think you'll get the idea of all of this.
Um,
we,
the,
there's deeper reasons.
I mean,
again,
one way is to put it down to Asian tradition.
And that's not really any kind of an explanation.
Uh,
we like to think that people are rational around the world and that there's some
more,
more fundamental reason for it.
And a lot of the reasons that you all said,
what are some of the extra reasons that I sort of pushed aside for the moment.
One was dowery issues and some of you said some other things,
but there's a whole lot of things.
And the basic story is that,
uh,
in certainly in India and also in traditional China,
the girl is brought up by the parents.
It gets married at quite a young age and by young teenage,
uh,
they get married and get shipped off to the sun.
The husband's family where she works is then counted in that family and has
worked,
usually worked very hard and a servant,
basically a servant in that family.
So the family that raises her has the problem of,
of,
uh,
investing in that girl putting a lot of money to raise that girl.
Then justice,
she's able to start working seriously and maybe return some labor,
some serious labor or some money to the parents.
She's gone and she works for some other family.
And so this is economically a very bad thing.
And the,
the people called raising girls like watering someone else's garden.
And then on top of that,
when the dowery system is as strong,
which it is an Indian going crazy a minute marriage,
they have to provide a lot of money and this can go up and to be like a year's
income,
uh,
easily to,
to,
to get the girl married.
And it's great honor thing.
If you have a daughter,
you have to get her marriage so you have to pay dowry or your family's honor.
It goes away.
So,
uh,
this idea that the girl was his is just passed away at the adjusted the time she
can be a value to.
It's kind of the rational actor theory of why this all this female
discrimination,
anything strike you unexplained about that.
Why is it that it's the girl that that goes away all the time?
Why can't the man go away?
This is by the way,
characteristic of human societies.
I may have mentioned this to a timeline to genetics shows when that males in a
village or related,
they've stayed there for hundreds of thousands of years and females move,
move out.
So x Aga,
me,
and where have you seen Exxon gummy before among the chimpanzees where the
females go out.
And so as far as we can tell,
this is a vestige from our very original biological roots where our reproductive
system requires,
not that the males fight each other and the males disperse,
but that the males stay together in a military situation and the females,
uh,
go out.
And so it's this very basic form of a,
you can call a chimpanzee social organization that leads to that the females go
out and therefore the females are of no value to the family that brings them up
and therefore they're discriminated against.
The men stay together and they have to have a protective protect the village
against violence.
In some places there's a,
there's a,
a,
either a tribe or a cast as you'd call it in India than I,
ours,
which are very military kind of cast.
What haven't they get married very young.
But then the man may or may not like spend one night with the wife and then he
goes off to the military and meanwhile the wife has all kinds of sexual
relationships and it's quite formalized,
quite legal day.
The women live in one big house.
They don't really recognize it's a,
it's like the nod that you read about it.
It's a female lineage society.
And then upperclassmen are invited in to sleep with these women and produce
babies for them.
And then the men have 15 or 20 years of military service.
Then they come home.
And only really at that time do they pick up,
uh,
the marriage.
And so again,
it's very clear in this particular cultural manifestation,
it's very clear thing that women are,
the reproducers men are the military ones.
And as in chimpanzees sort of a communal sexuality that WHO's the biological
father is not a particularly important.
Okay.
Now I want to switch gears here.
And in the time we have left,
and we were telling this whole lecture was about South Asia and South Asia and
East Asia are the centers of female disadvantage,
but that doesn't go on in all of South Asia as I've mentioned in Muslim
countries,
that basically does not happen.
So we're going to talk next about,
uh,
two places.
One is Iowa and the other,
I'll tell you in a,
in a moment.
And uh,
so I was a rich place,
right?
What does Iowa rich from
agriculture.
Corn,
so very,
very fertile place.
Well,
let me go,
go back a little bit.
So I will tell you the country don't,
I'm going to talk about
if I can find it.
Oh,
okay.
Again,
we worry a lot and have induced some of the Asians to worry about the sex ratio
that all these men won't get married.
But remember,
we're seeing sex ratio disturbances of of 12 to 20%.
And Remember in Europe I showed you this slide that a lot of places,
only 30% or 40 or 50% of people got married.
So the marriage imbalance,
uh,
is much,
was much more severe in Europe for hundreds of years than it is now in Asia.
So the marriage pattern and the social system in,
in Europe,
uh,
made for more extreme situation.
Then,
uh,
the female disadvantage in Asia.
Okay.
There's not a great slide,
but this is Bangladesh and what's in here in Bangladesh?
Is it since this is the Himalaya Mountains and here is China,
Nepal,
Bangladesh over here,
India over here.
And this is blown up a little bit and what you see is,
this is the,
the Bay of Bengal here is that the Ganges river comes out of the Himalayas.
The MLA has stretch all across here.
The Ganges comes out of the,
the,
the western Himalayas.
The Brahmaputra comes out of the eastern Himalayas.
Bangladesh has lots of water and this is all delta.
You see this stuff,
this is all delta from has through geological time.
As the river wanders around,
it puts down a delta out here and this is what the Delta actually looks like.
There's a reading that you have,
which says that the place is so good that people are trying to move out and move
out onto this land and try to farm on it.
And then of course a monsoon comes to the river,
the water rises and they're wiped out.
You'll have a reading about that.
But keep this picture in mind when you do that reading.
So now let's,
let's do the,
this story on,
on,
on the agriculture.
So,
uh,
the people in Bangladesh are Bengalis,
of course.
And the Bengalis are a large group that are split actually between Bangladesh
and,
uh,
eastern or northeastern,
part of part of India.
Oh,
Yo.
Rich Calcutta is the capital.
Dhaka is the capital in,
in Bangladesh and Calcutta is a capital Westbank on which is part of India.
So partition,
split Bengalis into two groups.
Uh,
Bangladesh is a very homogeneous country between Pakistan,
India,
and Bangladesh.
The three ones,
or the old British Raj,
98% of them are Bengalis.
So they speak the same language,
have the same cultural tradition.
In 88% are Muslim.
So unlike India,
which you cannot talk about as a whole,
you can really talk about Bangladesh as,
as a whole.
Bengal is a very rich part of the world.
Uh,
the moguls who ruled from the 13.
So the mobiles were Muslim invaders from apparently I think from Afghanistan.
Uh,
Concord,
north,
north India,
north of that part.
And they ruled it from the 13th century onward.
They called Bangov the paradise of nations in the 16th century when European
traders came,
they were ecstatic over bangles abundance and enriches.
Uh,
so why was it so rich?
And you have to,
for that,
I want to compare it to Iowa.
The uh,
size of Bangladesh.
It's fifth 56,000 square miles.
It guess what the size of Iowa is?
56,000 square miles.
So they're,
they're very close to the same size.
Both are very basically agricultural.
Maytag makes washing machines are used to in Iowa,
but they're very heavily agricultural.
But Bangladesh has a much better climate than Iowa.
They grow three crops a year in Bangladesh.
It's nice and warm there all the time.
But Poor Iowa,
anybody from Iowa here,
they can only grow one crop a year.
They grow winter wheat some,
but basically it's one crop a year.
Ben Gall,
they can grow three crops a year.
Uh,
Bangladesh has plenty of water.
I showed you.
They have nothing but water there.
So they're,
they,
they never,
they never have droughts.
And,
uh,
I was not bad for that.
And it has Mississippi River on one side than Nebraska River on the other side.
Uh,
but inside I where the rivers are all very small.
So we go to the edges.
There's rivers has been inside,
not a huge amount of rivers and they sometimes have droughts there.
Uh,
both are fertile.
Bangladesh,
which shows a low Illumio plane.
So the way land gets naturally fertilizes water,
rush,
glaciers in the mountaintop grind,
the rock and that glacier flowers,
it's called,
gets into the river,
dissolve somewhat in river.
And during flood season it spreads all this silt over the farm land.
And that's silt.
The minerals in the rock are the fertilizer.
So Bangladesh has this,
this,
uh,
floods from the Himalayas that covered basically the whole country.
And it gets it's fertilizer for free,
gets lot of fertilizer and it gets it all for free.
So again,
the agriculture is,
is looking real good.
Uh,
but Iowa does not get this except at the margins when the Mississippi,
uh,
floods and sometimes the Nebraska floods,
so the interior of the country,
they have to go and buy fertilizer there.
So by all these geographical kind of considerations and climatic kind of
considerations,
uh,
Bangladesh should be much richer than Iowa and you compare to three crops a year
to one crop and you know,
something like three times as rich.
But Bangladesh is per capita income.
I was incoming 17 times larger than,
than Bangladesh's.
And the difference is basically all population I was population is 2.9 million.
Bangladesh is now about 140 million,
so it's like 40 times a difference.
Bangladesh is 40 times as much population as,
as Iowa and compared to every other place in the world.
Here are a variety of places.
Uh,
here's Bangladesh way,
way out in front of everybody else.
Netherlands is considered,
you know,
of,
of other places.
The next most common placement is also an agricultural place,
but per both these have,
they don't have big mountains for deserts or anything.
So all the Netherlands is basically fertile and all of Bangladesh has basically
fertile.
But look at the difference in population and density and everybody else is less
than either of those two places.
So,
and as you know,
uh,
as I've just mentioned,
the,
the income in Bangladesh is distressingly poor.
It's one of the poorest countries in the world.
And the estimates are that it's population may double before if and when
stabilizing.
So things are,
it's going to be very hard to make things better in Bangladesh.
Well,
going back,
uh,
Bangladesh had a stable population.
They had a kind of traditional Burkhart,
very high birth,
very high death rates of the population,
grew very slowly,
if at all.
But about 1880,
uh,
population started to take off.
That's when the,
the again,
colonialism and whatnot,
the death rates started to climb and they started adding about 3 million people
every decade and sort of 3 million extra people do.
And in a country the size of Iowa,
not,
not tiny,
but not especially big either.
Well,
there's some jungle,
there was some jungle in Bangladesh.
They cleared that and they started farming.
But by the late 1930s,
the jungle was just totally gone.
No more jungle land.
In 1938 beer and Ganguli Bengali himself wrote,
quote,
every inch of land that is fit for cultivation is already used.
Every pathway or cattle track is pared down by farmers on either side until it
barely leaves room for two people to pass each other on,
on this narrow track.
Uh,
so what did people do as the population kept increasing,
they started moving out onto these mud flats that I've shown you,
which are very temporary.
And the cyclones come in,
not only is their sort of normal flooding from,
from the rivers,
the cyclones come in and you start getting these enormous death tolls in a
period of time in Bangladesh from climatic problems.
But it was really,
again,
a population problem,
just like the deserts that I told you about.
People shouldn't be living on these slats where they're going to be wiped out.
Uh,
periodically,
uh,
there was a for a while,
almost a hundred thousand deaths a year from storms,
erosion and flooding from these kind of just,
just considered deaths from climatic water stuff.
And so it took about 60 years of the population increase from Bangor becoming
on,
uh,
going from one of the rich places of,
of the world,
not industrialized,
but rich on their agricultural produce to what we standardly described as a
basket case.
And now all the focuses on Africa,
but not so much longer ago.
Bangladesh was considered justice as in bad shape,
uh,
as Africa is now that we constantly on the news stories of disaster in
Bangladesh and uh,
you supposed to cry at that and,
and give money.
Um,
so Bangladesh was clearly one of those places that was caught in the one
[inaudible] traps,
the arable land.
And this is a somewhat old figuring the population of the grease delight is 0.1
heck tear per person.
That's a quarter of an acre of person.
Just to compare that,
any of you from foreign places,
how many of you from foreign places every year?
I always get it.
Get some,
do you know what,
what's the size of the,
of the farms where you live?
Where do you live?
Outside of Cleveland.
Okay.
That's not one of the big phone,
but do you know roughly the size of the farm?
No.
30 acres.
Okay.
So that small,
that small farms out west,
it can be thousands of like the real commercial farms,
thousands of acres.
And here's 0.1 hectare for president here in,
I used to live in Bethany,
which is sort of a north west suburb of new haven.
And our house was,
our part of Bethany was zoned for three acres and I didn't have to live off it.
I just thought it was just a house on that.
If you had a house,
you had to have three acres.
So that was enough to that in Bengal and Bangol,
Bangladesh,
30 families would live on this three acres at,
at,
at 0.1 hectare per person.
So all of the indicators in the,
in this time starting,
say in the 1950s or sixties,
uh,
was that,
Bangladesh would not be a country in which you,
where you'd find a desire to limit fertility or the practice of Dolby
limitation.
It's,
it's,
as I've said,
almost all Muslim and it's a conservative version of Islam.
Their infant and child mortality was high.
25% of the children died before the age of five,
but that had been coming down slowly as I showed you for roughly 20 years.
Women have very low social status there.
Most of them in,
uh,
we're subject to Purdah,
which they not only have to,
to dress,
so they can't be seen when they're outside of the house,
but they generally couldn't go outside of the house role unless accompanied by a
male member of the family.
And,
uh,
men were fairly free to,
to abuse women.
And I read you the first lecture.
I think some cases the battery acid being thrown at women in more recent times
so that,
that still continues.
Last time you mentioned that one of the reasons that people want children is for
old age security.
Who's going to take care of me in my old age,
and of course Bangladesh was very poor,
had no social security system.
So the families were across dependent on uh,
children for the old age.
They were dependent on sons for their old age.
So that meant you had and have a lot of children,
make sure that it can't have a daughter.
You've got to have sons to make sure that you have somebody to take care of you
during the period of time.
I'm going to talk about,
uh,
Oh,
here are some of the major disasters,
uh,
in,
in Bangladesh over time.
So this is one really very famous one.
The Bengal famine of 1943,
world war,
they were red.
They were ready on the edge.
And then World War Two hits and the variety of things happen.
And uh,
two,
uh,
two and a half million people,
this is in filed,
two and a half million people die in the famine.
Uh,
here's some of the cyclones,
various psych clones that a war when they were trying to get independent of west
Pakistan,
they had a war and these things happened,
another site clone floods or,
and so all kinds of,
uh,
problems be set.
The country now here during this period,
uh,
that,
that is the critical period for population issues of the per capita GNP.
The gross domestic product basically didn't change little bit up,
but not,
not enormously.
It's basically had a flat per capita economy per capita GDP.
So again,
the,
the total economy was growing,
but more and more people ate it all up.
So basically the per capita GDP doesn't change in this period.
Uh,
what,
uh,
what happened was that
Malthus had been in India and the India,
the whole Indian subcontinent paid a lot of attention.
Multiple.
So they have been aware.
India,
Pakistan,
Bangladesh had been aware of population issues and aware of the mouth ASEAN and
ideas about it for a long time.
And the British of course trained they're civil servants of the countries when
they got an independence it with the same people.
So this was in their mind.
So in fact the South Asia,
originally Indian Pakistan where some of the very first countries to institute
family planning programs and then after the one in Pakistan was not particularly
successful.
The one in India is now much better but did not start out successfully.
But after the war of independence,
when Bangladesh split from west Pakistan,
the government really was aware of these problems,
how to Malthusian attitude and they really decided that they must start to get
some control of their,
of their population.
So they,
the government supported and instituted family planning program for the whole
country and international organization said,
okay,
you want to do this,
we will help you.
And especially there's a group called the international diarrheal research
organization,
which was one of the ones that had
discovered and pushed the oral rehydration packets.
You know,
many,
many huge numbers of infant deaths in poor countries.
Do they get diarrhea and diarrhea?
The bug doesn't kill you,
but you lose enough water through the diarrhea that you die basically of
dehydration.
And all you need to do is to have a little packet,
a water salt.
And sugar.
And as long as the water is not terribly polluted,
uh,
the,
the child will say live and eventually kick out the virus or the bacteria.
So it's international dire real research group,
very well respected.
And they said,
okay,
we will also,
we will also help you,
uh,
with family planning programs.
And uh,
what resulted was a countrywide of program.
Now at this same time,
we're talking the early 1970s,
most of the developed world,
uh,
had the idea that they,
what they say they so rich countries,
I have few children,
poor countries have a lot of children.
What's the cause?
Well,
money is because when you get rich,
you want to have fewer children.
We're going to have a lecture on that very interesting phenomenon.
So the developing country,
a lot of developing countries and east European countries rejected the whole
idea of family planning as a way of improving the economy and said,
no,
development is the best contraceptive.
That was,
that was the rule.
Development is the best contraceptive.
That there's no way in a poor place like Bangladesh that you're going to get
fertility down because of all these reasons that we've mentioned.
But if you develop the country economically,
then it will naturally come down and the government doesn't have to mess with.
It,
doesn't have to set up family planning programs.
So everybody predicted strenuously that Bangladesh could do what it wanted with
family planning programs until,
and unless they develop economically,
they would be,
uh,
no,
no progress.
Um,
so
what they did
was lay,
they,
prior to this program,
they had tried a variety of things in Pakistan,
one of the Times as well,
people are culturally into having a lot of children.
And so he must work with their culture and must work with the traditional birth
attendants.
So in Pakistan,
including Bangladesh,
it at the time,
uh,
they had a women called [inaudible] who are basically,
um,
local health providers,
herbal women,
uh,
mid midwives for births and,
and stuff like that.
But they had basically no,
no modern training,
uh,
whatsoever.
So in the first implementation of Pakistan's program,
uh,
they,
they gave these diaries various forms of birth control and they were supposed to
give them out.
It didn't work.
Why didn't work?
The days themselves were older women in general who did not use contraception
themselves,
did not think it was moral,
did not think it worked,
uh,
and had all kinds of bad attitudes toward it.
So someone tries to sell you something and they don't themselves believe in it
and you generally don't,
don't accept it.
Uh,
plus economically they made very little by distributing these kinds of
contraceptive from the government,
but they can make quite a bit more,
uh,
by,
um,
by attending the births that they charge a good bit for breasts.
Would the government sent the little bit?
They wanted to have the contraceptives very fairly free to the people.
So they didn't pay the,
he's very much so the dyes would get all the condoms especially and sort of
buried them somewhere and claim to the government that they had distributed them
and then made a lot of,
not a lot of money but their money from attending the bursts that that hadn't
been averted by the so so it didn't work.
But they you learn,
I mean these are the,
again,
the first countries in the world to have family planning program.
They didn't know how to do it.
You have to not given that this is the way you do it.
So eventually they,
they started the program that I described to a somewhat last time,
um,
where the women can come out of the house.
So you hire a high status woman from that village known to the women has high
status,
is herself using contraception,
thinks it's a wonderful thing.
You train her how to deal not only with the woman but the woman has very little
power there to deal with the husband to deal,
especially with the mother in law.
And for that you need a high status woman that can go into a house and start
discussing these things.
Cause even talking about anything to do with sex for reproduction is not,
uh,
is not a socially acceptable
thing.
So they started this program and uh,
initially
you got this kind of a of thing and uh,
Vena Siddharth talked about this,
that when you start a family planning program,
this is an old older version of the family planning program.
Not,
not the one I've just described.
What you see is they took,
uh,
there was a place called [inaudible],
one of the districts in uh,
in Bangladesh and they chose some villages.
They want to know whether what they were doing was successful.
Some villages they gave this family planning program too and other villages they
didn't as a,
as a control region.
And here is during this period up to 1977,
the comparison area where they didn't do anything special,
the government had a small program but nothing much was happening.
Now the international diarrheal research group comes in with this somewhat
updated program,
not,
not the the one I showed you.
And what happens immediately.
There's great success and they're jumping up and down.
Okay,
it's true,
but then it peaks and then over time you'd falls down.
So what's happening here is a small fraction woman,
well 20% is not terrible,
but a small fraction of the women before the program comes in or want to limit
their births and you'll give them anything they accepted immediately.
That's this initial rise.
And that's very standard for family planning programs that you get an initial
rise and then it falls off and over the longterm,
if you're evaluating the program here,
you think it's wonderful,
but if you're evaluating the program here,
it's kind of worthless.
And Vina was talking about that,
that she comes out of this Economic World Bank perspective and they're very
impressed with with these periods of time.
This is a program that in retrospect we would say really didn't work well though
it helps a fair fraction of the women.
But then you put in a good program that I described to you and now what happens
a later time.
So we stopped the previous graph,
stopped in 77 at this level of contraceptive,
uh,
ex acceptance is that a program that didn't work,
then they start sending these village working women into the homes of the other
woman and now you get another big rise that this is now successful immediately.
But now the,
the success continues.
Meanwhile,
there's modernization in this social diffusion that these areas,
the comparison areas are actually intermixed,
uh,
with the treatment areas.
And they hear a lot about what's going on in there.
And so for that reason,
and others are not,
we don't really have data to say why it rise.
But even in the comparison area,
it starts to rise.
And in one of your readings about Taiwan where you'll have a family peg,
very similar kind of thing,
it makes big point that there they did have some data that they had villages
where they had a family planning program and then as soon as this was heard
about in the surrounding regions,
people would come into the treatment region to get treatment.
So the fertility goes down.
This one of the factors behind this is certainly a diffusion of,
of,
of the ideas of family planning.
Uh,
so this,
this thing in,
in,
in Bangladesh has,
has had terrible significance for what we believe about,
uh,
family planning and programs and people's acceptance of it.
Because up until this time,
it was really dogma that you have to have economic development and you have to
have some degree of literacy and you have to have some degree of,
of women's status,
uh,
before people would want to limit their fertility.
Then you go into Bangladesh with a,
with a well funded,
well thought out,
well run program and it starts working and now Bangladesh is,
uh,
it's fertility has kept falling and it's in there with a lot of countries that
are a lot richer than it.
India is a lot richer.
Egypt is a lot richer than Bangladesh and they all now have come to more or less
the same kind of fertility level.
So it,
it,
it now is no longer really believe it's believed that women almost everywhere in
this case,
it must be the men because the men and the mother-in-law's control the issue
really do want to reduce fertility.
And if you give them the option,
they will accept it
along the way.
Um,
other places have learned other lessons.
So India next door,
uh,
had a much stronger central government because of the Gandhi effect.
Andy was such a national hero to all the ethnic groups in India.
So the government was strong and Nehru was very strong and,
and neighbor's daughter,
Mrs Gandy was very strong and they were westernized and under the Malthusian
influence and they decided that they need a family planning program also.
Actually India was even before this.
Uh,
but again,
they didn't know how to do it and they decided to use incentives.
That's what,
you know,
economists keep telling you that every time you're taking an economics for
people respond to incentives.
And so they decide to use incentives to get people to take on a family planning.
And there's a lot of debate about this issue of incentives.
And one part of it,
one article I read about people in villages in Nepal,
like the one that,
that,
uh,
being it was in pretty far,
they have to take a whole day off from work to go down to get a contraceptive
and they have to go back and what kind can they get because they can't go this
every,
every month to get something new and they,
they can't take time off from their work or their chores.
So it's a real major economic expense,
not the contraceptive itself,
but the time and effort needed if they have to take a bus and maybe very
expensive in their economy,
uh,
to that.
So part of the idea of,
of,
uh,
giving incentives is to just repay,
the woman for her time and effort and India,
it started out that way,
but the program was not very well run.
It wasn't,
they didn't have the big international help to Bangladesh had and program wasn't
terribly well run.
And so they sort of got frustrated at,
at the results and their population kept going.
And it was a time in India way before this current boom that India has been
going through.
It may or may not still be going through.
Uh,
and so the government got frustrated and the population grew and there they saw
their hopes.
This was window of opportunity that I was talking about for modernization,
for populating.
It gets too dense.
That window may close.
So the government got,
uh,
got desperate and started
introducing some coercion.
They were,
uh,
some of it is,
is incentive,
like a transistor radios to the man to get the men to get sterilized.
And,
and that was wonderful,
but who got sterilized with the old men that weren't going to have children
anyway,
but they get a transistor radio or,
or some money out of this.
And the whole thing crashed.
And it came entangled as an America reproduction and politics.
So the opposition,
uh,
to the people didn't especially like it cause it's changing their culture.
And uh,
but the opposition took hold of it and blew up all the abuses that were no
question.
There were abuses blew up,
the abuses,
the newspapers bled the abuses.
And it became a very big political thing.
And,
uh,
the Congress party government fell,
because of that.
India has since sort of,
they then they went to a period where they sort of did nothing in family
planning because it was in such bad favor and now they've started up again and
think things are going a lot better.
So I think the,
the,
the story of this is that
the idea which was prevalent up till the Bangladesh experiment that only rich
countries,
they're going to reduce their fertility is just plain wrong.
And now as the,
as the fertility,
uh,
transition goes through Asia,
it's now amazing places,
uh,
very poor places.
What,
what's happening?
So sealon was one of the first countries in Asia to get down to replacement
level.
Kara,
very poor in salon is not a rich place.
Carola,
one of the poorest province of India is down at replacement level.
Uh,
all kinds of countries,
Thailand,
Indonesia,
all have really reduced their fertility at amazingly low levels of per capita
income.
So income is clearly important.
When it doesn't want to throw it out,
it's,
it's perfectly clear that things are easier if you have more money and there's
reasons why Richard people have fewer children,
which we'll go into,
but it does not a necessary prerequisite.
Okay.
We will see,
oh,
have a good vacation,
enjoy,
come back refreshed
and I will see you then.